[Music]
jackson's in salt lake city hey jackson
welcome to the ramsay show
hey dave can you hear me yes sir
thanks for having me sure what's up
so i have a little bit of a dilemma i
made more money than i thought i was
going to this year and i
so i ended up maxing out my roth 401k
and both my roth ira as well as my
wife's
roth ira
but my income is looking like it's going
to be around 230 000 i had a really good
queue for them in sales
i'm wondering what i can do well your
401k is not affected by that but only
the two right individual roth iras uh
who have you got those iras with
uh so one is with uh well actually
they're both with fidelity okay just get
in touch with fidelity they can walk you
through it you've got to undo that
transaction because you can't go
straight into a roth making over 200k as
you have already discovered what you can
do though is go ahead and just set those
up to be
an after tax
traditional
ira and you can do that and then after
the first of the year you can roll them
to a roth
and that's after the first the year you
said that's called the other but you got
to move them to an after tax first
move them to an after tax so you're not
going any penalties or any problems
anyway because you haven't paid in taxes
and you you know the the income is
taxable now and it wasn't
it was going to be taxable when it went
into the roth and it's still taxable so
it doesn't affect your taxable income
either way but move them into an after
tax and then you can ira and then you
can roll them into a roth from that
after january 1. this is the last year
you can do that that's called a backdoor
roth ira
biden administration in the latest round
of um
uh legislation did away with the back
door i'm surprised it lasted this long
it's been there for many many years and
everybody kept talking about closing the
back door the purpose was uh you know
there's it was a workaround is what it
was it was a legal way of doing a roth
when the didn't meet the guidelines i do
i've done an after tax and rolled it
over every year i've done a backdoor
roth every year and sharon has too we'll
do our last one this year and then we'll
just keep smiling and move right along
uh i have to ask chances that that ever
reopens no never again no it should not
have been there it was an anomaly right
in the law the intent of the law was not
to allow high-income earners to do roth
iras that was the intent of the law
and so um unless somebody just came
along and said oh it's okay for you to
save money now
but that would be
a novel thing to happen around congress
or let's let wealthy people actually get
tax benefits too oh no they're evil they
must be punished later i did it i
revealed that i'm a capitalist pig dude
yeah we knew that